did you end up submitting to any Film
Festival's its recent minute a lot of
film festivals we we picked out the
biggest ones that the ones that we were
really psyched about going to maybe
maybe 10 8 10 oh yeah I mean more than
that well though that was like the first
round that was the first run and then
and then that was that way then we've
all we were like okay we should let's do
some other ones too like second-tier
festivals maybe and then we'd learn 16
of those so I mean there's a lot of cost
associated with the shipping and and
just yeah everything with that - and
submission fees obviously submission fee
is copies of films - and we mailing yeah
I mean I have no idea how many we
submitted - to be honest if I if there
was a lot there were a lot of festivals
that we submitted - but we didn't get
into any we got some very nice letters
back saying you know keep trying we like
your film there's just not enough room
for it kind of a thing yeah some
handwritten letters me they send they
send you and they send everyone Michael
yeah a couple places like actually wrote
us and Hamlin oh my god what does this
mean something like in your submission
there's somewhere more delayed than
others yeah but eventually everyone ever
we ever we found out from everyone what
our status was but yeah some were
delayed but oh yeah we you know he'd
called me I was in Wisconsin and he
would call me and be like yeah we didn't
get into this and we didn't get into
this those are stressful days because
again we had we had money and we didn't
know exactly how we had money allocated
towards distribution if we had to do it
on our own
but we didn't know how we were to go
about that let's say no not to mention
all of our Kickstarter backers
supposedly were funding us for film
festival yeah I think we're getting into
any so we were so meeting all of these
things I mean great a lot of those
things were also like cost and adverse
yeah like ADR work
print material which we end up having to
still do yeah I mean we definitely used
all the yeah dollars towards the project
but you know when they're when you're
saying you know help us fund is Film
Festival run and then we get shot down
by every festival I mean yeah there were
some long months while we were getting
into film festivals but especially when
everybody you see is like so what's you
what's the deal with the festivals you
know how's it going did you get into
celeb dance and they're like no and
they're like oh man that film must suck
mm you know to get in or did you get
into Sundance like no like man how did
you not get into Sundance and it's I
don't think anybody realizes how
difficult it is to get any of these
festivals like the campaigning that you
have to do at times to get into them I'd
seen him I don't know I might not even
know I'm talking about because I've
never been any of these festivals so it
might be maybe our film sucks campaign
do you mean you think that there's an
extra step just me not just submitting
the film about having all the materials
but there's something extra yeah no no
like like the overall process oh it's
it's a lot to do yeah I mean times 45 at
first they were like I don't care and
then like after a while they're like I'm
cool yeah yeah there was a lot of
heartache getting rejected over and over
and over again but at the same time we
knew that even if we did again and we
were still gonna move forward so like we
always said no matter what no matter
what happens we're gonna do whatever it
takes to at least get it out to the
public some way yeah so self
distribution is specific yeah like we
were mean we were even discussing that
we're talking about doing a second
campaign on Kickstarter or going to the
bank and trying to get a loan and doing
and we've been the third campaign
can't face me brother the same project
and and just self distributed you know
but a lot of that's foolish because we
don't one we don't have the resources or
the knowledge to dive into something as
complicated as self distribution
you